you just explained that like you're a
machine learning thing tagging it like
extremely visually compelling
high engagement to the end like you know
i've seen i've seen too many videos at
this point i have to put them in the
buckets
[Music]
colin and samir do you guys know what
you're getting into do you know what
this is at all
i thought this was a podcast about
procurement
is that not what this podcast is about
yeah it's all about office supplies i
don't even know how to say the word
procurement once you get once you get
around us
that word becomes a problem right and
ben is the systems integrations guy
right yeah exactly yeah
yeah and so give uh give y'all story so
i i kind of know a little bit of it but
let's assume people listen to this don't
know it which is my way of saying i kind
of only half know it but give give me
your story
yeah
um so i'm samir by the way uh this is my
voice if you're listening um i graduated
college um in 2011 and i went to school
to study film and digital media and i
grew up in la so i was like really into
the film business i wanted to be a
storyteller i wanted to find a way to
um you know become a filmmaker and that
was a really challenging thing you look
into so how did you how did you swing
this i'm going to be a filmmaker well
he's good looking though too i mean he
looks like an l.a person i know but the
parents parents don't care about that
no you're right i mean i remember the
moment when i called my mom and i was
like i'm not going to
be a business major i'm going to be a
film major uh and it was a scary moment
i think for them but i was a bad high
school student i was not good in high
school i was just not getting college i
didn't do homework i was not someone who
really lived up to the standard of what
it was to be an indian kid whereas my
brother was student body president uh he
became a lawyer like he he followed more
of a traditional path i think
they had noticed that i was so
unconventional that it was like all
right at this point do whatever but my
dad's also really unconventional he's an
entrepreneur he's a fashion designer
like he's he's different um so i think
there was a bit of like okay i mean you
seem confident figure it out um
and and so for me when i graduated
school
you know i had a i had an issue with
being someone who wasn't
good in school like i i didn't i wasn't
great at like
being an employee
that was really hard for me i worked as
an editor
on a film called ides of march in
hollywood and i just i just didn't like
it i didn't like doing a single task i
didn't like doing you know one thing
and
i had become aware of of youtube
primarily because i was up in in
northern california in college and
was really fascinated by it so i felt
like i had all the tools to to just
upload a video um and just make
something
and the subject matter that i picked uh
was the community that i was a part of
when i grew up i grew up playing the
sport of lacrosse i played lacrosse in
college and i decided to spin up a
youtube channel called the lacrosse
network
and
that is the origin of my first upload
onto youtube really outside of like
student films
and at the same time colin was uploading
a series or uploaded a trailer for a
series about the colorado club lacrosse
team i'll let him pick up from there but
um this is this is in 2011 uh just for
frame reference let me jump in with one
thing i've seen a video where you said
something dope calling you go
my first video only had i don't know
what you said like 100 views or a
thousand views you're like but samir was
one of them and that view that one view
changed my life because then you guys
ended up joining forces you guys do a
bunch of cool [__] fast forward till
today you guys got this like
pretty baller youtube channel and this
is like you get to do the thing you want
to do you get to like
i don't know if i can do anything i'd
probably be like a professional
basketball player that'd be like the
the peak of like getting to play
and like be super successful at the same
time uh but i feel like the second best
thing might be being a youtuber and uh
and so like you know that's i love that
idea though that like
okay i only had 100 views i only had a
thousand views but like that one view
changed that one of those views changed
my life i thought that was like an
amazing
little like nugget
yeah i i think for me it was a real
lesson in in community probably unlike
samir you know i actually was
a really dedicated student almost
probably to a fault
and so when i finally had this
experience in college of you know buying
a camera and being a little bit more of
a creative
you know putting out my first video
which was about the lacrosse team having
it not necessarily be a huge success
but you know it did connect me with all
these like-minded people one of which
was samir he sent me an email that day
basically saying if you're going to be
making these videos even though you just
started why don't you put them out on my
network because i'm trying to aggregate
tons of
people who are fans of the sport so you
know from that point on i was like i
don't even
care about my past education i am so
interested now in just telling stories
and having it connect with people but
that didn't
the
the lacrosse network that was like kind
of a failure right like it got you to
like a certain point and then you're
like [__] this isn't going to pay the
bills is it because
yeah i think i mean i think it didn't it
didn't it definitely didn't pay our
bills in the first three years right um
it was something that was
not a failure but you know
yeah i mean like long story short we
sold the company in 2014 which was
really positive um so that was a success
for us but
like the pathway to get there was really
challenging because there was no
business model really surrounding
youtube in 2011 2012. um when we tried
to to get advertisers no one even
understood that spending money on
youtube was a reasonable thing to do
that was like the only way people could
understand us was a video production
company so what we did to make money is
we did creative jobs for people like
service jobs okay yeah well we you've
seen that we can make pretty good videos
on online we can make you a video
or we even did even more creative odd
jobs we made websites for people we
designed stickers for one company it was
just kind of like oh these guys are like
creative internet people so if we have a
creative internet task we'll we'll ask
them to do it and then what what was
beneficial to us was that youtube the
company was was very interested in what
we were doing and they basically came to
me and they said if you can secure live
rights we'll really get behind you
because we're trying to explore live
sports on youtube
and that's what i did i i got rights to
um high school games first then college
games then we eventually distributed pro
games and
figured out how to acquire live rights
and um get youtube behind us and that
kind of grew our profile and got us to
the point where we we could um we got
acquired by a sports media company
and a lot of that you know i would say
it was an aqua hire to be very clear
like the benefit of that was that you
know there was cash exchange for our
company but really the majority was in
you know we had salaries and stock um
and
we got to actually have like very
comfortable stable jobs pursuing youtube
and exploring not only
there's a company called whistle
yeah um
so by the way i want to say something
here youtube started in like what 2005
something like that yeah yeah and you
guys are saying it was 2010 2011 and
you're like it really wasn't like uh
well a well-trodden path of like
be a youtuber make money doing this this
can be like a business and this could be
the platform versus the way you guys use
it was kind of like it's kind of our
portfolio and we'll get some clients
from this and it'll be a launch pad
maybe maybe we'll get picked up by
somebody else bigger like real
traditional media that will pay us
that's kind of crazy right that's like
six years into the game and that's why
like right uh just a bigger point about
like let's say crypto right now it's
like these things take a long time
before they become a thing before it's
like
what youtube is today where it's like
obvious now that you could be a youtuber
you could make a bunch of money you
could be mr beast whatever
it's still not even obvious if you i
don't think it's that obvious yeah yeah
i don't think it's that old at least
there's examples
like i watch youtube on my apple tv and
that's tv to me most people only like
only teens do that and like i'm the old
guy most people i don't think do it like
that but i think like so i think it's
still pretty like
not a thing yet
i do think if you take a step back and
look at it it's it operates exactly like
most media companies uh and that's like
if you just take business models from
the past like how the radio operated or
even how uh you know television operate
like any media company a magazine like
that's that's how youtube operates too
there's a really unique version of
advertising when it comes to youtube in
that
we are uploading and the platform will
actually pay us
without us having to interface with
clients without us having to build a
media kit without us having to pitch
anyone which i think causes creators to
not fully understand the business
they're in because they don't have to
pick up the phone
and sell their audience to someone or
sell what they're doing to a client
if they're primarily based on the
adsense that youtube's giving you when
we were first starting out
adsense was absolutely insignificant
because our audience was extremely niche
it was small and youtube was not that
developed there were people making good
money from adsense checks on youtube
which is you know again the money that
youtube will pay you uh part of their
partner program but
you know that's never been that
significant of a check for us because
we've always been very niche and so
we've had to learn the business of media
um
and apply that to what we're doing with
youtube and i think you know that
maturity is starting to catch up right
now in the space and why a lot of
creators are able to build businesses
today and why there are road maps and
fast forward to now you have uh the
lacrosse network's uh no longer the
focus it's the collins the mere show and
it's basically this it's a youtube
channel you have hundreds of thousands
of subscribers and you kind of talk
about like
creator economy stuff but i think that's
a little bit niche but
like it's it's a little bit more than
that but you've got these like really
highly produced interviews that you do
with people but then you also have all
these like clips and you do this thing
where you're sitting in your car and you
like give um
analysis of like different videos and
why they're going viral but you do it
seems like you do a little bit more than
that i watch i watch it all the time uh
and so is that how big is that business
at this point just to give the audience
like a little who don't know you like to
to a little sense of how legit you are
sure yeah so yeah as you mentioned we
were you know we're on our way to two
million subscribers uh we have 800 and i
think 13 as of this recording
the business is myself colin and we have
four full-time uh team members who work
on uh the actual channel that's uh
myself colin we have three editors uh as
well as a production manager uh and then
a data and insights person uh who who
works and and looks at like kind of how
everything's tracking from an analytical
perspective and then we also have a um
a newsletter and there's a team of three
that works on that two people one one
general manager of the newsletter one
more in business development and and
sales um
and then uh a writer who's who's on
staff for the newsletter so the total
like people who work in the collin and
smear ecosystem is ten um and it's split
across two media properties one being
the youtube channel and one being the um
one being the the newsletter
i don't know if you guys and i would say
i would say too like we're primarily
supported with advertising advertising
based business
uh our biggest clients are samsung
shopify jelly smack and other crater
economy companies what's the revenue now
can you reveal or no
yeah we're i would say we haven't been
super 100 transparent with like exact
numbers but we're a seven-figure
business
are you getting close to eight
no
do you guys think this uh like gets
there like basically sometimes you get
in a business and it's what got us here
won't get us there and sometimes we just
got to keep on keeping on and um so so
from a business model point of view is
it if we just keep okay we're at 813 000
subscribers today we're probably
tracking to 2 million next year or
whatever it is and the ads will just
keep scaling and this will keep going
this will be the business forever or is
it like we're going to have to come up
with a second act at some point
so i think there's decisions you can
make as a creator to get there like we
we are friends with a lot of creators
who you know are pushing towards that
eight-figure business mark right and and
a lot of that is is at just ad-supported
business um
there's other creators who have launched
you know course companies or education
direct-to-consumer content patreon right
subscription platforms and you can
absolutely get there it's just honestly
i think it's based on there's this
moment as a
an artist or filmmaker someone who wants
to express something where
you go from like i mentioned i studied
film i was very interested in being a
filmmaker but you go from being a
filmmaker to a media maker and i think
that um those are two different things
and you have to decide like colin and i
have to decide
what we want the lifestyle to look like
i think you guys mentioned i think it
was your mother-in-law sam who said i
like taking tuesdays and thursdays off
i think that's a really important thing
for all creators and all entrepreneurs
to look at and be like
what what's enough uh for me like what
what is
what you know what i want to do and i
think colin and i this is like a
relatively recent
um
success that we're having with this
channel and we're trying to constantly
evaluate which parts of this are really
enjoyable and which parts of this start
to feel like okay now we're just making
stuff to make stuff
and i think we have to find that balance
of
uh how to scale what we're doing but
also recognize like we we got into this
because we we wanted to make something
and i think it's okay to to lean in to
be like maybe there's part of this
that's like we just want to tell the
stories that we're excited about and yes
there's a ton of opportunity but it
might not match what the lifestyle that
that we eventually want
who who is crushing it so um like you
mentioned some creators do x y z like uh
what's his name ali ali
he's coming on on the pod soon oh he's
great i think he reveals his numbers
where it's like okay my uh my course
business is gonna do like two million
dollars this year or something like that
yeah where he basically is like you know
become a youtuber or some [__] like that
it's like it's a course that's around
the world so six million uh i think he's
tracking to six million this year okay
amazing youtuber academy yeah i signed
up for timer youtube academy so that's
the
so that's the course he does and so
that's an example of like
um somebody's crushing it in the course
model then uh sam you've talked about
the guy who does like bring a trailer or
which one was it the the car doug domoro
you guys have doug
we bought a car from cars and bids for
one of our me too
me too amazing great so he is a car guy
with at this point two or three million
subscribers and he has a
a an auction website for cars that could
potentially be a nine-figure company i
actually think yeah sam was that
launched off the channel or before yeah
no he had the channel for five years
maybe
many years
i think the unique thing that we're
experiencing right like this is
entrepreneurship um the difference is we
build an audience first and then solve
how to you know monetize that audience
through products services subscriptions
whatever right um whereas a lot of
traditional entrepreneurship is build
the business first and then try and find
customers or audience second um and so i
think that's when you look at like
creators how big this can become it's
really like how uh for a lot of creators
who built successful audiences and niche
audiences it's like how big you you want
it to become the thing that's holding
back the creator space right now i think
is is operators like really good
business operators to surround creators
because
to make you know like to make on a
consistent cycle when you are the
subject of your videos uh it doesn't
really allow you to operate as you know
the the
business admin the operator the person
who's pushing cars and bids uh the the
website and and that business while
you're making the content at the same
time
ask your question again sean
yeah so what are some other examples so
let's take those two so ali abdel with
the courses doug domoro with uh you know
has a car channel then launches a car
auction site who else has done something
cool what are some other cool stories of
people crushing it that are like
started with content started with
audience and then have done have created
a cool business off their youtube
channel that that's impressive because i
don't know particularly
that like are not mr beast the ones that
you know we all know about yeah yeah i i
would say an interesting one that keeps
coming up is cassie ho she started blog
a lotties so
like fitness yoga instruction on youtube
and now she has two separate product
companies that are both eight figure
companies right samir
yep yeah there's one that's like an
apparel company for athleisure and then
um one that's like yoga mats uh and like
[__] i i yeah i think like that's
that is another yoga creator called uh
yoga with adrian who started teaching
she's so great uh but her subscription
platform's amazing right like she she's
her awesome man i'm a customer
right yeah have you seen this
uh shawn her name's yoga with adrian
she's got like the girl next door look
where she's like not intimidating but
she's definitely beautiful and she's
based out of
austin and she does yoga with her dog
and she's very calming
she's the best man i love yoga with you
know let's see this
there's another creator named amanda
rayshlee and she started creating
content with bullet journals so she was
showing like how she was setting up her
bullet journals how she was um
organizing her days uh and then she's
launched a line of stationery and of
journals and that's become her primary
engine um of business and and like i
think
those are a few specifics i think yes
theory when it comes to merchandise and
apparel i think they've done an
incredible job with seek discomfort
and building a brand that can stand
alone outside of the videos
and i believe they also just went into
the fulfillment business so they not
only have their own merch line they also
do the printing right the warehouse
for other creators too right
that's right i think it's really smart
when creators start uh businesses like
that where they say okay if we're going
to solve all these problems
independently and not go with a partner
then
you know
we can work uh we can work with other
creators to do the same do what i think
people should be doing that you you
don't see so i have a couple ideas i if
you don't have one uh i'll throw a
couple at you you could tell me if
they're why people are not doing that
maybe they're bad ideas but what do you
think creators should be doing that they
haven't yet gone into that that realm
yet it's not common so i actually have a
perspective that i think um
i i think i i'm curious why we haven't
seen creators band together especially
like let's let's imagine the e-commerce
space like why have we not seen 10
creators come together and launch an
e-commerce retail store um like that to
me where they can bring a ton of traffic
to it and and pair together and all
their audiences or maybe on one brand uh
yeah i think that's exactly what i was
gonna say like a disney store discovery
store type of thing
100 or even like one singular brand it's
happening with this brand called cloak
in in like kind of the gaming world but
like why not just if if every creator
had a piece of this one apparel brand
like couldn't you make the next big um
apparel brand or could you make the next
urban outfitters if if you know emma
chamberlain plus five creators came
together and made a retail store
i feel like specifically in beauty and
fashion and cosmetics like there's such
an opportunity to band together and have
one brand because there are so many like
stand-alone cosmetic brands for a
singular creator but it can it can
really happen in any like in gaming this
was ha i always thought this should
happen in gaming so my company got
acquired by twitch so when i was there i
was looking at like okay what are these
creators doing one brand that stood out
was there's a brand called g-fuel i
don't know if you guys have heard of
it's very like gaming niche but like
basically sam i don't know if you've
heard of this it's like um i don't know
what you it's like a red bull it's like
it's sort of like an energy drink uh but
a g fuel as in gamer fuel so it's like
oh this will be you know give you energy
help you stay focused when you have
those long gaming sessions what was in
it and
it looks like a gatorade who knows
what's in it like and the guy who
started it he's like this absolute like
50 year old bro like he's like yeah 55
and just like jacked to the gills and
you're like oh wow this is like i don't
know what's happening in this company
but i don't want to drink this but like
what would happen is they would go to
they were like oh dude these twitch
stars have influence but the traditional
brands aren't going to them they're
going to instagram and youtubers first
so he went to them and he was like hey
i'll make a flavor for dr disrespect
i'll make a flavor for ninja i'll make a
flavor for each one of these and you'll
have your own shaker that you'll like
kind of promote that has your brand on
it and like he had these like he got
like nine of them to be like the
sponsored athletes basically and they
they grew pretty big i don't know what
they were doing exactly if i remember
correctly it was definitely over 20
million it might be over 50 million in
sales that they were doing just off of
like kind of this one real niche channel
um
and uh what i thought about was like and
then and then each of the individual
creators was doing their own thing like
ninja made a mouse a gaming mouse and
then somebody else made a a another like
a coffee or a stimulant or whatever
and i was thinking the same thing if
these guys just got together and the ten
big ones got together
and they just launched a gaming
accessories thing like the best keyboard
the best mouse the best whatever like
they would be selling hundreds of
millions a year if they like put their
powers together captain planet style i
think that goes back to like the lack of
operators in the space right now um and
i think it's starting to catch up but i
do think that
you know there's a lot of short-term
revenue to be had um and that's really
exciting and there's a lot of there's
like quick cash to be made um in in our
space that i think now it's probably
just happening where you're starting to
look at these longer term and there's
like you said there's more road maps you
know of course
you know mr beast is in my opinion
singular like it's he's not you can't
there's not going to be more uh
of him but you can look at some of the
stuff he's doing with oh feastables is
interesting or even logan paul and oh
they made prime instead of partnering
like that's interesting and they how's
that going together
i i'm not positive i would i from what
they say it's going well so that's uh i
think that's all we know uh i'm not
positive i will say it tastes great uh
we bought it here and it's like a
fantastic drink but i have absolutely no
idea how the business is going
i would say too it seems like he's
following the beats by dre
trajectory of making sure to get it in
the hands of celebrities and famous
people with his podcast anytime he has
someone on they have prime in their hand
or they try it and they like it it's a
good strategy when you guys got to how
long how long did it take to get to 800
um
for i think at least four years right
call at least four or five years i mean
yeah yeah probably four years to get to
200 and then one year 100 to 800. yeah
so let's let's take this journey one
second i got a question on this so
if we strip away hard work and talent
because let's say those are like core
ingredients that you guys have
um but like every journey has like
inflection points like something where
something just broke your way or you
realized something before others did or
like
the one thing went viral and that kind
of helped step you up to another level
because like if i go to the channel
today i see the the top thing is like a
video with miss an interview with mr
beast has 10 million views right and i'm
like how the hell did they get mr beast
like that's a big poll yeah that was a
great interview
so what were the things that were like
besides hard work and and consistency
and talent
what made you guys grow and what made it
work how do you get to a million
subscribers and mr beast do an interview
with you guys
um
my first answer is time and market um i
think like we've been in this market for
10 years and that has introduced us to a
lot of people that have created
opportunity for us as we started to grow
right like
jimmy
shot us a message jimmy's mr beast um he
shot us a message when we made a video a
couple years ago and he was like that
was a cool video and we struck up a
relationship and we started talking
about youtube because we were both
really into it um and authentically into
it and that created a situation that you
know when we got to a point where we had
an interview show or talk show
we had a relationship with him such that
we could fly out get access in north
carolina to his new facility and like he
was excited to to be on our platform and
we we had that relationship and i i
think even when i think about an
inflection point for our business prior
to that
was when we you know really were weren't
catching that much traction from a
sponsorship perspective but we had made
some connections to the point that um
you know samsung was looking for
creators to partner with on like
year-long ambassadorship deals and our
names were were up there because of the
relationships we had created in in the
market so i would say the fact that we
just stuck in it for 10 years has
introduced us to people that created
opportunity as i would say we are late
learners and we've
like figuring out youtube took a really
long time for us um but as we figured it
out we were in a position where we had
enough relationship that you know our
first couple interviews are like marquez
brownlee mr beast like we were able to
have these creators on
um who we had developed relationships
with prior that now fit into a format
that we had landed on um and
collaboration on youtube is like that's
how you grow um you know
time and market is an awesome way that's
an awesome phrase i've actually never
heard that before time in market is a
great way just because typically we
would chart and i would just say like
well i'm just like in the mix and i was
just like i've been doing it for a while
yeah time and market is a far more like
formula people usually use it for
investing right like buffett i think
said you know instead of timing the
market what matters is time in market
and uh it sounds pretty similar uh for
what you guys are talking about i would
add too that it's it's time in
underserved market
because you know the reason that jimmy
or mr beast even reached out to us is
because no one was really talking about
creators or about the youtube space for
a long period of time
and we continued to talk about it while
no one really was giving it the time of
day so i feel like it's not that we were
just in the market it's that we picked
an underserved community and so
we happened to be that place where
creators could turn
that's so
uh in crypto that's happening right now
like i created this crypto media company
not long ago called the milk road and
it's doing really well but we're so new
and crypto's now cool
so you don't get credit for being there
when it's cool there's a guy there's a
show called up only that's on youtube
that's uh started by this uh this guy
kobe
and uh leisure or whatever and they
they've been doing it for a long time
back when like there wasn't a lot of
heat in crypto they were still just
every week going on and just talking
about whatever shooting the [__] talking
about crypto and so now when
famous people want to go hit the circuit
they're like well we got to go there
because they have the respect
of people because they were set they
were hanging out here before the
tourists arrived you know and uh yeah
you can't you can't beat that
no i agree with that i think like you
know we watched the
people go from being not interested in
what we were doing on youtube to
extremely interested and then a lot of
those people who are interested in the
creator economy i think shifted over to
web three and so like i think
you'd like time and market when you're
just like actually like this is the this
is the career we've chosen like we're
going to be in this we enjoy this this
is what we want to do this is what
brings us fulfillment then you know
wherever this goes uh the ups and downs
of it we're just we're just here right
and so like i think that is uh that is
an important thing um as you're as
you're going on your entrepreneurial
journey
so right now sean and i have a really
like our our podcast is doing great um
we're not we're we're a pot we're like a
podcast that sometimes it's posted on
youtube and and and so podcast numbers
are first but we've each
uh toyed around the idea of like maybe
we should give this youtube thing a try
like maybe like separately like in our
own like our like you know like we'll
pick a niche and go at it and i've
thought about it but i'm like you know
i'm not ready to go whenever i'm gonna
do it i'm gonna go all in on it and like
maybe hire someone to help me do it can
you give me and shawn some advice on
like look here's like the here here's
like the table stakes in order to get to
a hundred or two hundred thousand
subscribers inside six or twelve months
here's like the the absolute minimum and
keep in mind like assume that budget
this is it for most people assume that
budget is no big deal like we're willing
to spend money
so here's something that i think is
really important is like you're creating
a video podcast so in your mind the
thought is there's not much marginal
cost in posting this video to youtube
you're already we're producing a video
and audio right now
there is not marginal production cost
there is marginal distribution cost
you're going to have to spend time
thinking about
how to distribute this show on youtube
and how that differentiates the audio
think beyond so think of it it's like
sean does i do something on
fitness well
sure
anything building houses i don't know
yeah i think like you do need to go all
in you need to understand the audience
that you're serving and most importantly
you need to understand packaging and
what works on youtube from a search
perspective and what works on youtube
from a click-through rate perspective
all of youtube is is click-through rates
and then retention right tell me what
did you get
yeah
what works
no i mean you're saying
you're saying understand what are like
what are you getting at
what's what's the niche that you would
want to tackle entrepreneurship
uh let's say i'm just gonna make let's
say um i bought a bunch of i'm buying
airbnbs let's just use that for an
example
shortcut
yeah short-term rentals yeah so i think
like you would want to um
go along from a packaging perspective on
uh basically how to make money through
airbnb rentals right so maybe you would
create a series that's like zero to a
million dollars in revenue on airbnb
rentals episode one right and it's and i
wouldn't title it like that but like
call i don't know if you have ideas on
titles but i think brainstorming titles
would be our first step from an audience
perspective because you're trying to
transform people to understand how they
can do the same thing correct
yes that would be my assumption yeah so
call i guess let's let's spitball back
and forth titles on something like that
well even that first thing you said
that's a like a story frame right like
zero to a million and
rental income
you set the stakes already like i'm a
man on this mission which i think is not
what most people would just naturally
think to do but for you guys it's like
well if you have a mission people are
going to want to see if you can do it or
not and how to do it they might want
that too
yeah i think for that example too people
are people are doing that and that's not
a problem um that actually can be to
your advantage a lot of times we tell
creators you know if there's something
you want to talk about search it into
youtube sort by most viewed and see what
are the videos that are getting a
million views there are definitely
videos about you know the business of
airbnbs buying airbnbs that have over a
million views so i think that's a good
place to start
uh in your journey is like what's
currently working you know and then what
are those videos about like i think the
key for you would be how can i actually
make sure that when i get this title
thumbnail that's pretty sensational
about making a certain amount of money
or you know converting some house or
something like that how can my video
actually meet the expectation of the
person who clicks
you know that it's not maybe you just
sitting down talking about it
retroactively but you know maybe it is a
video that took you two months to make
or three months
who knows you know but it's got to match
that expectation and be actually
impressive
i think probably packaging it around
like i made a million dollars on airbnb
um in 30 let's say let's cut the stakes
to 30 days and basically over the next
30 days you're going to track how you
went from
not making any money on airbnb to even
like how do you make money on airbnb so
i think that's that's the packaging
you'd have to
uh fall into and then you'd have to meet
that expectation like you'd actually
have to do that
and then i would think about like where
where are people currently getting
airbnb education outside of youtube are
there places that are actually really
popular where those communities already
hang out where if you made your video
you could seed it to them or it would be
a success if they started talking about
it and sharing it organically what would
you think about where on the internet do
they exist what would your early team be
would you have just an editor someone
filming you would you have a thumb a
thumbnail maker what would what would
your your skeleton barebones team be
for you i think if if you said that like
money is no option right that's that's
not real yeah just for the sake of just
for the sake of argument yes
yeah i would hire a
thumbnail designer who
is is part youtube strategist most
thumbnail designers have a lot of
youtube strategy in them as well um
because they're they're so linked so
yeah i would recommend trying to find
someone who uh
really deeply understands packaging
uh and has seen things that work i'm
gonna read some titles and uh maybe you
guys can guess the viewership in this
exact category um
how to make your first million on airbnb
i mean i would think that's over a
million yeah
900 views
oh 900
yep you can make a million dollars per
year on airbnb in 2022 with the you in
all caps
oh i hate that that probably has fused
i'm gonna say low i'm gonna i'm gonna
hope and pray it's low is it low
eighteen thousand
okay
i would say that's medium how much money
my airbnb made in its first month high
that one crushed it that's probably
shelby church is that shelby church
shelby church 235 i love her that's
right so so i think already through that
exercise you're starting to understand i
watched that video by the way that's how
i know it's great
i love her do you know who shelby is
sean
no
she's great yeah she's amazing shelby
church is amazing but i think like
that's where do that exercise in
packaging like just go through all those
and then the ones that are not working
upgrade the titles yourself
like what was wrong with that title what
was wrong with that framing did that not
match the expectation uh and then for
shelby like what was right about that
that framing is really great how much
money my airbnb made in its first month
great yeah me and sean talked to this
woman named rebecca what was her last
name rebecca z
she's got a zamarollo or something like
that she's got a she's got like across
all of her things maybe 10 or 15 million
subscribers she makes content for like
12 year olds um not like little kids but
12 or 10 12 year olds where it's like
plays and stuff and uh
she was i was asking i was like man she
was like yeah like i i we got to like a
million subscribers pretty quickly i
think like
within a year or two years and i was
like that's amazing how'd you you know
what was the thing and she was
explaining it to me and i was like okay
so basically what you're telling me is
that you just like quit your job and
like you just made this like you're nine
to five and you just focused on it and
she was like yeah like no one else
treated this like a job and this was
like yeah i'm at the office at nine i'm
working until six seven 8 9 10 sometimes
but i'm showing up every single day and
i'm just like i'm working and versus
most people they're just kind of like
[__] around it's like oh i'll get to
it when i get to it
yeah and i think studying as well like
really being a student of the platform
like that's a that took five minutes to
look at some of the top performing in
that category and
dissect what you thought was good bad
what worked what didn't work um you know
i think you have to do that first it's
like market research
i can't find this client info have you
heard of hubspot hubspot is a crm
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases hubspot grow better
is there a good tool that shows you
search volumes on youtube so uh like you
know you could do this with google
search you can figure out how many
people are searching for these keywords
can you do that within youtube
yeah there's a tool called vid iq that
you can use there's um
we do it on google a lot because again
like google and youtube are obviously
you know connected right so what do you
mean on google play people are searching
like google like google translate
keyword tracker google search trends
google translate yeah yeah we'll use
google trends to track like okay is this
keyword better than this keyword or
people searching this more than this but
you know on on youtube specifically we
do use vid iq sometimes um
and i'll tell you like how competitive
maybe that that keyword is is there a
lot of search traffic on youtube for
that and it'll also show you the uh top
videos for that keyword so if you if you
go into vid iq and you type in airbnb
you're gonna start to see like okay what
what are the trending videos in this
category what's working what's not
working what are the thumbnails that are
working
um
and do you guys like vidiq is a great
example of
as you guys try to be successful on
youtube you're like ah this is so i wish
it was easier to do this type of
research and not just see what's popular
but how competitive it is and just
quickly show me the top videos in that
thing right so vidiq becomes this piece
of software that you guys might pay for
you know is useful to you guys what are
some business what are some tools or
things you guys wish existed i know this
is a little bit of a hard question but
like
there's i don't know hundreds of
thousands of entrepreneurs who listen to
this that will like hear that be like oh
i could build that i could start
something like that where you guys
aren't gonna have the time to build it
necessarily but what are some
opportunities you see that could serve
youtube creators the two things i wish
existed when we first started and that i
still think there's opportunities for
are legal zoom for creators and uh turbo
tax for creators and i know those two
things exist for entrepreneurs but
something with a more creator lens uh
and i know there's people starting these
now but i think those are really helpful
um especially on the tack side i think a
lot of creators like
because you just have this influx of of
freelancers essentially who are now
starting to like they it goes really
fast from okay i made a little bit of
money on youtube to okay wait a second
what do i what do i do now i just made a
ton of money on youtube um so i think
some of that would be really helpful of
you know the back end business side is
what you need the most help with you if
you're into it like if you go nine to
five into youtube you're gonna figure it
out if you're really into it you're
gonna figure out your niche your
category uh how to find audience time in
market baby time in market like you're
going to figure it out you you might
have to hedge your bets and have another
job while you figure it out or have
another source of income but if you're
really into it you're going to figure it
out it's it's the back end of you know
that the younger like being 21 and all
of a sudden landing figuring it out
really quickly and then being like what
do i do now so i think some of that
business ops that business admin stuff
would be really helpful um
to to help with creators um to make sure
things are like clean and and growing
right you were talking about uh like
partnering or like you well i mean what
you were saying was about operators
creators need more operators and in my
head i'm like oh that's cool you just
like
um someone like me who knows how to
operate a business i just partner with
someone like you who's like famous and
we do like a 50 50 split and and i build
a business that you just keep getting
famous and i agree that that's a great
business but in that example as well as
the example in your guys's partnership
and as well as just like a normal person
who just wants to bail what happens if
one of you guys dies or you get in a
fight or you want to quit um is your
business just going to die you know are
you going to be done do you think about
this i know jenna marbles i think is
huge on youtube i'm pretty sure she just
bounced like she just said i'm out same
with casey neistat he goes i don't feel
like making videos so does your money
just go away
i think creators
are a lot like athletes like i think the
term creators and athletes are kind of
like you can think of them in similar
ways so it's kind of like if if we stop
playing like yeah your income from
playing is is gone uh i think it's about
figuring out that the businesses that
can support you outside of creating
videos because the reality is like
you can't sell colin and sameer and
expect someone else to operate it if one
of us is gone this version of collin and
smear is done um that's the reality but
the things we build like it's it's a lot
of why we built a newsletter because
like we were like okay that follows a
similar value prop it's similar in
creating content i'd say sam like
inspired by a lot of what you did and um
you know like hey we're educating people
about this space we think we can do it
in this way we can hire writers we can
scale our voice and our thoughts and if
we're gone that thing can operate um
it's not called the collin and sameer
newsletter right you know it's called
the published press for a reason uh with
that goal in mind that that it truly can
scale beyond us but what we do is is
unscalable beyond us um and i think we
we we're okay with that um
you know
so i think if we if we were to separate
in that hypothetical
uh
something were to happen
i would hope that like
let's say i'm no longer around i think
samir like could continue the interview
show that we're currently doing and
serve the brand partners that we have if
he wanted to do that
that sounds like colin's thought about
it yeah that sounds like no i'm just
saying like
whereas whereas in the past we had a
format
we had like a really high lift format
for creation that just wouldn't have
worked like if one of us was gone it
wouldn't have worked but right now we
have an interview show we have a talk
show yeah well you know it wouldn't be
the same but like you could carry it on
what craters surprise you have you come
have you guys interviewed anyone or come
across a channel where you're like dude
this fishing channel that just says fly
fishing is making a million dollars a
month or
like has there's ever been anything like
there's a guy i saw who has a channel
just on
uh breaking into locks and it's got like
it's a huge channel there's another
channel that where they just smash stuff
it's like a it's like a press i forget
what you call it yeah but a hydraulic
press is there any channel that you come
across and you're like man these guys
are killing it no one knows about it or
at least mainstream doesn't know about
it man i wanna i wanna pull up the exact
name but it's a barbecue channel there's
like there's a whole barbecue genre on
um youtube that's massive and they do
huge partnerships with like brands that
you know colin and i would never
interact with right like sweet baby rays
or stubs or um and they're like starting
to sell their own rubs right like spice
rubs and those are really high margin
and like
that genre to me is really interesting
and people who are into barbecue are
really into barbecue um so i love that
genre i think that's like they're very
good businesses there when it comes to
selling spice rubs um and barbecue
accessories i guess
i'm always amazed by
channels like the slow-mo guys where
there's literally no need for language
it's just the visual of something
happening in slow motion and the
viewership is so high because those
videos can be watched again and again
and again all over the world no matter
what language you speak that youtube can
place ads
globally
in every market and so just the revenue
that they get from youtube the platform
is out of control uh
that to me is a fascinating business
where it's just let's film something in
slow motion and rake in massive
advertising dollars dude you guys want
to hear something [__] up so sure
there's this channel that i follow and
it has a huge following and no one talks
about it because it's really
embarrassing
so
there's this there's a group of people
i'm one of them
that we we like uh like popping zits
but to take a step to take it a step
further there's one where people love
seeing dandruff come off people's head
and so because because like when you
have dandruff you like scratch you're
like i need to get this out it's killing
me
and sometimes you can't do it so when
you watch other people at least for me
when i watch other people do it i'm like
oh i feel the relief like it feels
relieving for me to see that and there's
this guy i think it's just called like
the indian
dandruff barber and he takes guys with
dandruff and he shaves their head and
you could see it all like you could see
like his scalp get like cleaned and uh i
was with my friend neville recently and
i went to his house and i turned on his
youtube and i go hey let me show you
this video it's hilarious but don't
laugh at me i think i'm a creep eddie
and i uh she went to that video and it
was purple he had already clicked on it
and i was like dude you [__] guy you
want just dandruff [__] too
and it's there's like this whole genre
of people if you watch if you do like if
you type in like dandruff removal
there's so many videos of people who
just love watching or another one is
like uh uh like seeing sis you know what
assist is like a lump in a body seeing
those get removed i [__] love those
videos i love them
dude
you guys don't watch that don't make me
feel like a freak i don't know no listen
listen when if i come across a good
pimple-popping video i'm diving in like
i'm not i don't shy away from that and
i've seen the indian dandruff guy i
don't think i haven't seen that um i
also there's one account that i like got
really weirdly into which was the
folding lady on tiktok she just folds
clothes in different ways and that's it
and like organizes them in her drawers
and my drawers are a disaster so it's
like this for me it's like this
aspirational account that i can watch
where she organizes stuff well there's a
lot of weird stuff out there
and how do you guys look at tick tock
because this tick tock is this like
younger sexier
version of youtube it's like you know
you're the 37 year old actress
and now you see this you know 21 year
old come on to the scene and you're like
oh no
what's happening over here you know
what's the perspective on tick tock for
from your guys's point of view
i i see con i see tick tock as a bit of
like a content accelerator that like if
you're new to
content creation and you want to find
out what works faster
then go to tiktok because it's a low
barrier to entry to post
and
if something doesn't get viewership no
one really sees it like there's not much
weight on it because of the for you page
which is like this
talent show style format it's like if
it's good it'll find people if it's not
whatever it doesn't feel like with
youtube
you know when you start a youtube
channel it feels like a statement you're
like i'm here to make my own version of
some big media company
and
you know that is there for all of time
every time you pivot every time you make
a bad video it's just sitting there in
your library whereas tick tock it's like
it's not as much weight on it so just
move fast put something out and i think
it's a great place to find
audience i don't know if it's a great
place to monetize that audience though i
would say i think a big reason for that
is because it's the it's like the
closest thing to a leanback experience
right like you just turn it on and you
say whatever's on the free page like
it's really good at finding content
that's good for me i might not go in
there and search for a creator
that's like not really a behavior that i
think a lot of people do it's just like
you feed me whatever's good here so
let's say you take out the top creators
on tick tock like the absolute top
creators um
all of our tick tock experience wouldn't
be changed that much like it would still
find content that's interesting to us so
it's actually not a great place for
creators it's a great place for content
it's not a great place for creators to
build relationships with their with
their fans that's why most tick tock
creators move to youtube to build that
they can build like longer lasting more
depth with their audience they can build
a library of content that you know you
know cruise viewership over time
it's it's where like you would if you're
serious about the career i think you'd
move to youtube
um tick-tock you're you're you're there
like tick-tock is the creator you're
putting content into their
system um so i think that's an important
distinction between the two what's
like you guys are not as bullish on tick
tock like i've kind of thought about
like i'll give you an example um
i put out a tweet the other day sam i
don't know if you saw you did you did
see it you called the guy an idiot and
you're like this guy's an idiot you
should hire him um
this i put on there he's being like
i just want to hire a great content
creator because are we talking about the
milkman yeah exactly yeah okay i saw it
so so this guy i tweeted out this thing
saying i'm hired content creator you
just gotta be great at content and we
will we have distribution we'll help you
accelerate here and uh for the milk road
and we i get this tweet back yesterday
that's like
for those who haven't seen it it's on my
twitter you can go find it but it's this
i don't know colin you tell me i thought
it was amazing but maybe it's just
because it's about our thing was it
amazing to you guys it was to me
i think that's an extremely visual
compelling piece of content with uh
in a format where i have to watch to the
end
you get to see him struggle to try and
finish that gallon of milk you just
explain that like you're a machine
learning thing tagging it like extremely
visually compelling
engagement to the end like you know i've
seen i've seen too many videos at this
point i have to put them into buckets
summarize the video sean
so the guy is basically like hey um
you know you're hiring i saw your tweet
you're hiring a content creator and he
like he used our joke for my first
million i've moved straight to the end
he's like so i've moved straight to the
end here i am i've got a gallon of milk
i'm gonna drink this to show my
commitment uh i don't even know what his
premise was but he's basically gonna
chug a gallon of milk in order to show
how bad he wants this job and he made a
funny tick tock out of it with the
editing and he's like asking people hey
can you hold this camera i need to drink
this milk he's like in a car mechanics
place they're like no
he puts it on the ground and he just
takes off his shirt he just starts
chugging this milk and it's just awful
and then he's like has little cuts in
between where he's like
why couldn't they have called it the
juice road
because he's like having to drink milk
and like you know just little funny bits
like that and he whenever he finishes it
he celebrates he pours the milk all over
his head at the end and he's like
whatever he sends that over so i hired
him so i tweeted out i was like this is
amazing you're hired i just talked to
him on the phone before this and he's
like all right like what's the game plan
and i was like well
i think the first thing we got to do is
we got to pick the channel we want to be
on because i think the platform will
dictate what content works on that
platform um and so like
like i have a buddy steve uh steve
bartlett who who says this uh which is
like you need to hack the algorithm like
you need to understand how the what the
algorithm wants and then you have to be
able to serve it to them uh if you want
to grow like faster than normal and so
and so we were debating like should we
start on youtube or should we start on
tick tock and in my head i'm like
i use both i love both products but tick
tock does definitely feel like a um
i don't know it just feels like
the growing wave compared to where
youtube is and so i'm like i guess if
you're starting fresh you would just
start on the platform that's like more
of a growing wave and like try to make
it happen over there though
but that was the downside is even if we
get viral growth from it like those
people may never see us or hear from us
again because it's just the way that
tick tock works so
that's why i was like i don't know i'm
not sure about this bet here which one
should we go for your guy's perspective
sounds like he'd lean more towards
youtube is that right well well honestly
yeah i was gonna say i don't think you
have to pick and choose necessarily
because
let's say you're gonna commit to short
form vertical content which obviously
you would put on tick tock right sure
you could post that yes you could post
the same thing on youtube shorts uh
as well as on reels maybe and like you
know keep that up for a certain amount
of time and see what takes off because
you may find yourself in a situation
where
youtube shorts takes off and all of a
sudden people are subscribing to your
youtube channel for shorts
and then if you wanted to transition to
a long form video you have a home for it
and that's a place where you could build
a deeper connection on tick tock you
don't really have that option right now
a long form youtube video i would say
like that's the highest barrier to entry
when it comes to content uh so i think
short form vertical is the lowest is a
lower barrier to entry not the lowest
like a tweet is probably the lowest
barrier to entry um but
like that is you want to take more shots
to figure out your format your style it
might take 100 videos to be like
actually that's our format that one
works or maybe you figured it out and
this guy's just got to chug milk every
day until you guys you know get enough
users
but like i think that's what it is it's
format development and you need a lot of
shots on goal to to
can i tell you my my first assignment i
gave them
yeah sure i was like all right here's
the first first thing uh
man on the street style interview you
know where you go like you've seen this
on late night shows you go and you just
stop somebody in times square you're
like hey bo do you know about this and
then they give you some goofy answer you
cut them together
i said uh
go outside of a strip club and ask
strippers if we're in a recession
and uh like ask strippers how the
economy is going and basically that's
what he's gonna do he's gonna go man on
the street style outside of a strip club
and then when the strippers come out
he's gonna ask him how's the economy
doing because they are the front lines
they feel it first you know they see
what you know
talk from all the from all the drunk
hedge fund guys yeah they get they get
all the scoop and they see the tips how
they're how they're changing cash you
know you know in real time so that's
gonna be the first piece of content
sure yeah i mean i think that can work
uh i think that's a very specific
audience and and it'll work for that
audience right so yeah dude what
happened so i don't know the point i was
going to the point where so our podcast
gets one or two million podcast
downloads a month and compared to like a
lot like a website that gets 10 million
i'm like i think
we're we have a bigger a big we don't
have a bigger but we have a far more
loyal following because people listen to
us for an hour at a time with youtube
they watch you for 10 20 30 minutes at a
time and i was gonna say i would have
thought that you guys had one or two
million ish downloads a month uh views a
month i'm looking at your stats on
social blade you were at like a million
a month every month 800 400 500 and then
all of a sudden you got to like 27 28 42
million a month what the hell happened
is that from shorts
that's a lot from shorts but shorts
propelled the other content like
basically the way we view shorts like a
lot of people had a lot of problem with
like oh you can't monetize shorts and i
was like but if i told you as any
business that i had a way that was lower
lift to get you in front of way more
people to get your brand exposure to
millions of people wouldn't you take it
um and that's what we did like right
when shorts kind of emerged we're like
okay we can make a short in a day
whereas it takes us a very like a week
to two weeks to make a a full long-form
youtube video um we can make a short in
a day and so let's just try it and as we
started to try it like we had shorts
that pushed
10 million views 20 million views 7
million views 8 million views and those
people were subscribing and then there
was concern like are those people going
to watch the other content
but because the shorts were you know
directly connected to the longer form
content we were just aggregating more
people who then watched our library of
content so it worked for us um
and that has fluctuated too i think
we're back like right now i think we're
in like the 9 10 million views a month
range on the channel um and shorts are
not like as big of a factor we're not
putting out as many shorts but a lot
more people are watching our library now
um and that is what youtube is like
you're building a library of content
that you know our mr beast interview for
example you mentioned it it's pushing 11
million views right now but in the first
month it did a million views so you know
you look at now it'll it'll be a year in
september it'll probably have 12 13
million views um
you know and so that's it's about this
library building a piece of content that
can be viewed over the next year or two
years five years
and when you do that it does have you
know this compounding effect especially
when shorts are added to the equation as
an accelerant
we have a we had a short go viral
recently and it's sean explaining who
like
one of the ball brothers is and i have i
don't pay attention any of that any
sports and they're in all the guys i
just randomly clicked on the comments
and they're all like these [__] guys
are idiots like he doesn't know anything
about lamar ball i forget who it is
shawn but yeah
yeah yeah and you're like explaining
this and people are just ripping us uh
of the short comments or maybe just how
you went viral really yeah yeah whenever
any of our videos hit that mass scale
that's when the comments sort of turn
and it's just it's kind of a good sign
in a way it's just just what happens
yeah there's one that um there's one so
we did this clip contest for the podcast
so we're like uh hey we'll uh take any
of our content you own a channel so you
make your own tick tock channel your own
shorts channel
and cut these clips and basically
we just want our clips out there so
we're kind of doing it different than
most where you guys want to you guys
want to build your specific channels
we're like you can call your thing my
first million clips or whatever and uh
go ham with the content you own that we
just want distribution and we give out a
prize for whoever like does the best job
each month of cutting it and people have
like what this so the first first winner
they
had a few million views on their uh like
tick tock channel or whatever and we
paid them the five grand you know prize
for our thing but they've actually
turned that into a business for other
podcasts and that business will do like
a million dollars in revenue this year
as like a you know pretty young kid
then
with this one just yesterday somebody
said oh here's the clip that's got 1.2
million views and it's this clip from an
interview we did with this guy neil
patel and he's talking about how he
spends like 180 grand a month that's his
like monthly lifestyle burn rate and um
and the title of it is like
billionaire ex like billionaire explains
how he spends 180 grand a month
and like the guy's not a billionaire but
like doesn't matter like the the you
know the kid who's running this channel
is probably like [__] that's gonna do
better then the top comments are like oh
like that's that's neil patel he's not a
billionaire and then like this guy's
like egging it on he's like question
mark question or question mark that's
his only response instead of being like
oh yeah sorry that's a mistake and then
somebody else says who is this guy and
he just
he writes the founder of google question
mark and then there's a hundred comments
being like that's not the founder of
google and i was like who is this genius
that's hacking the engagement by putting
dumb comments as the creator just to get
people riled up so that this you know
the algorithm sees that this video has a
ton of engagement in it i mean we've
played around with that a bit that's
that's that's uh definitely something
that creators do we've we've misspelled
words sometimes in our subtitles we've
um
we had a short where we we interviewed
the chief business officer of youtube
robert kinsel and the short begins like
we interviewed the we we wanted to say
we interviewed the head of business at
youtube and we said we interviewed the
head of youtube at business and just
kept moving on and like people
re-watched it so many times to be like
wait what did they say
so like i think there's there's a lot of
fun ways to play with that and play with
the audience and oh you know we would
never do that because sam would not like
do that like
now we wouldn't do that but this person
who's doing this has nothing to lose so
they're of course gonna like just crank
the dial up to level 12 of like
spamminess because they're like who
cares it's not my brand it's not my kind
why not yeah yeah
i think like your drake um steak
short like that that piece there's
definitely a short there right like that
was really fascinating um you could tell
that in a really concise you know like
one clip bit like that was really
interesting that you guys um
what you guys talked about and i think
like that was one of your better
thumbnails too i would say that came
across my recommended like but the
challenge there is that
your time stamp at 100 or sorry an hour
24 i think like anyone's expectation
might be like wait
is that an hour 24 on drake
and
steak um and then
you know there might be an opportunity
to just say hey can we just clip out the
part that was about that um and then you
know lead people to to watch the full
tank or listen to the full thing on
right on audio feeds i the the guys who
edit the podcast i think they also edit
the youtube so hey guys you hear that do
it please yeah i think i think that's
your opportunity it's like hey it's
actually eight minutes on on the drake
stake situation right and it that that
was your best thumbnail i think like
that that caught my attention that made
me curious
so yeah
well dudes thanks for coming on this is
sick um i've been listening to you or
watching you guys for a while
um it's really awesome that you came on
and it's awesome that you knew about the
pod so that was really cool and we
appreciate it this is great and of
course thank me and sean we both run
run or ran newsletter companies so
you've been helpful with us for new uh
videos if you ever want to shoot the
[__] about newsletters we got you
man that'd be awesome absolutely yeah
definitely we definitely want to learn
so yeah right on guys cool
all right
[Music]
you